by the way i have breaking news
how's this i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you
some breaking news right now what your
song for the james bond movie no time to
die just got nominated for a golden
globe
oh how's that no way
yeah i just got handed it
thanks for nominating us howard
you're nominated no it's true i hope
that's true i mean that's the the word
make that up did you
maybe i did i don't know
yeah going to the award shows you like
picking up the awards i i do i have to
admit
there are these two have seven grammys
yeah fun you know you know whether you
win or not it's a it's just fun it's
scary and intimidating and and that's
why like in the this year of covid i i
felt such like
i felt like really bad
but also for for the artists that were
kind of blowing up and covered i felt
bad for them and i also kind of envied
them because you guys don't have to do
the live thing
on stage in front of all these people
randomly like
you know they didn't they didn't have to
have the nerves of
of
you know on stage well not touring but
like the grammys the the grammys and the
you know all the award shows
the
2020 grammys
were the most
insane
thing in the world and
not just because uh of the awards that i
received but the whole night just before
any of that was just
so scary and when you perform it just so
i i had this like kind of jealousy of
like oh my god these people don't have
to worry because everything was
pre-recorded last year it was like all
these performances that were
pre-pre-taped
and
you know they could get all their vocals
right and they didn't have to worry
about it being live but then i also felt
really bad because
that intimidation is actually what makes
it really fun and makes it really scary
and feel actually like a real thing
um so i'm i'm really glad that right now
it's it's so far knock on wood
better and and we can actually do award
shows because they're i think they're
really fun i mean they're right it's
cool they're also a lot so sometimes if
you're if you're not in that right
headspace it can be rough but i i do
like them